ben parler à Cyril alors parce que lui
il est digne de vous alors ou mais c'est
vous qui me parlez moi je vous ai rien
[Rires]
demandé qu'à garder votre opinion pour
vous moi je m'en fous parler avec votre
maman votre cousine votre concierge je
m'en fous ça m'intéresse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas et aidur est avec N
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravoci c'est bon
[Musique]
année avec
[Applaudissements]
nous
bonjour ça va ma
chérie Afida tu connais tu as déjà
rencontré Gerard pardux moi tout
simplement je voulais simplement dire
que Gérard de Part Dieu moi j'ai grandi
avec Gérard c'est vrai que pour des gens
comme moi qui viennent d'un milieu
social c'est un exemple c'est un un
monsieur qui vient de châurou c'est pas
un enfant de la balle mais pourtant
c'est de la balle et on a tous grandi
avec Gérard pardieu que ce soit les
valceuses ou sirano c'est un exemple
pour nous pour tout ce qui est art
dramatique et cinéma donc quand on m'a
appelé pour me dire tu penses quoi de on
efface Gérard de pardieu et on supprime
ses films moi je me suis
prononcé en tant que fan en tant que
artiste et je trouvais ça un peu injuste
d'un mec qui a donné plus de 60 ans à
l'art dramatique l'art du sechemar qu'on
efface quelqu'un qu'on lui envoie qu'on
lui enlève la Légion d'honneur par parce
que il y a effectivement ce reportage
qui est fait et très mal fait
complètement enenquête c'est pas
complètement enenquête c'est
complètement de de coupe de tête parce
que c'est ces images sont faites en
sorte pour porter préjudice sinon on
passerait pas des images ainsi il y a
pas probl d'enquête FIDA il y a aussi
quand même des plaintes aussi pourou
attendez vous nêtes pas procureur ni
tribunal laissons faire la justice on
peut pas moi je moi ce qui m'embête
énormément c'est ce lychage médiatique
Gérard est un citoyen comme vous comme
moi il a payé son d dans l'art il paye
ses impôts qu'on laisse la justice faire
par rapport à ses accusations vous voyez
ce que je veux dire Mo tu connais pas
parce que tu l'app
gérardelle quelqu'un Gérard généralement
connais qui n'a pas grandi avec Gérard
de pardieu hein les valsus c'est un
c'est c'est c'est attends attends parce
attends attends j'aimerais qu'on parle
aussi avec les chroniqueurs de pass
gérardine avec les rétropédalages qui a
eu donc il a Ivan Attal qui a dit qu'il
avait regré patrist le conte aussi ave
un rétropédalage
ja Nadine trtigon Pierre
Richard voilà il et la plupart en fait
sont venus sur et vousida vous avez pas
fait de rétropédalage en revanche je ne
change jamais mon fusil d'épaule au jour
d'aujourd'hui les gens n'ont plus de
dignité et n'ont plus de couill voyez ce
que je veux dire parce que tous les gens
pensent à leur bifte moi je défends
c'est un citoyen laissons faire la
justice pourquoi un tel lychage c'est un
coupage de tête on le crucifie avant que
la justice ait fait son devoir vous
voyez ce que je veux dire je naime pas
la justice parce que moi-même j'ai été
victime laissez-moi terminer la sentence
moi-même j'ai été victime d'injustice la
preuve on m'a mis un un P je suis tombé
sur la tête de Cyr what the fuck Happy
New Years joyeuse fê voà quand on parle
de Gérard ça perdz Gérard je suis tombé
à vos pieds he voilàasas ton collier ma
chérie qui ah ce collier est magnifique
j'en suis tombé je suis bouleversé il
faut savoir que j'ai fait 8h d'avion je
viens d'arriver de Miami ah ouais
vraiment je viens de Miami à l'instant
donc c'est-êre pour ça que je n'ai pas
vu ce piège ce piège à con par
terre en revanche j'arrive de miam cont
je et je peux vous dire que c'est pas
tout le monde qui peut arriver de Miami
et d'arriver à 47 Bala coiffer maquillé
sur le plateau de C8 personne peut faire
ça donc ma première mission moi c'était
faire en sorte parce que Rolin le j
n'était plus dans dans la propriété elle
était partie en course ou je ne sais
guerre bref et c'était de faire en sorte
que cette dame ne remett plus les pieds
dans la résidence de monsieur ah
d'accord c'est incroyable donc vous vous
étiez un peu là pour dire si elle
revient la fout dehors pas la [__]
dehors puisquelle était déjà dehors
d'accord mais donc qu'elle puisse
qu'elle ne puisse plus rentrer que pour
l'instant que pour l'instant monsieur
Delon ne puisse plus enfin ne veuille
plus le qu'elle soit dans être en
contact qu'elle soit qu'elle soit dans
sa dans sa dans sa propriété
ouais c'est c'est fou non mais c'est
c'est fouou parce que si çaou il voulait
qu'elle rentre onempêche de rentrer al
alors donc non non il donc voilà et donc
vous avez travaillé avec eux donc quoi
juillet août septembre octobre c'est ça
jusqu'au 10 10 décembre de cette année
j'ai été j'ai été limogé par par les
enfants d'accord pour une raison alors
c'est quoi pourquoi vous avez été
renvoyé bah en fait la sécurité comment
ça se passe c'est même chez vous ici je
pense vous avez des agents de sécurité
devant les portes il y a ce qu'on
appelle un carnet de bord plus
communément aussi une main courante donc
voilà nous on écrivait quand je dis nous
c'est on était deux voire trois agents
de sécurité à tourner dans dans la
résidence quand moi je prendenis mes
weekends j'avais donc un relais et on
écrivait donc un carnet de bord une une
main courante et on écrivait tout de de
ce qui se passait donc donc voilà et
puis là le 10 10 décembre 2023 j'ai un
collègue qui a pris ma relève à l'F
Fabien l' gentiment il un petit peu euh
enin voilà il il lui a demandé ce que
c'était et mon collègue lu dire ben non
c'est une main courante écoute on écrit
tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur alors
justement c'est ça l'histoire il paraî
de ce que je sais je vous dis tout
chamid on m' dit c'est que vous vous
teniez et ça c'est ça qui est important
un carnet de bord dans lequel vous
parliez des svic enfin les fait un peu à
à Alain Delon par par ses ses ses fils
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas c'est un
carnet de bord qui où il y avait tout et
et n'importe quoi j'ai envie de dire
c'est-à-dire l'infirmière qui pardon
vous mettiez quoi dans ce carnet de bord
ce qui peut nous intéresser c'està-dire
sur le traitement d'Alain Delon par par
ses fils ou par sa fille il y avait quoi
les comportements que les enfants
auraient pu avoir avec avec leur papa
comme aussi je vous dis la chose la plus
lambda la médecine qui arrive à
17h55 est reparti à 18h30 vous voyez on
écrivait vraiment les entrées les ou
mais c'est ce carnet c'est ce carnet de
bord qui a fait que vous avez été foutu
dehors ça donc c'est qu'il y avait des
choses compromettantes dedans bien sûr
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y avait à peu près
enfin sans nous dire moi je voilà je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails qu'il
y avait je vous dis oui effectivement il
y avait des choses compromettantes sur
les enfants sur quels enfants surtout
surtout sur le plus jeune alin Fabien
alin Fabien qui qui quoi quoi par
exemple non quelqu des fois il avait un
pe pour moi s'il était un peu bord
enline on va dire avec son papa c'est
c'est c'est c'est vague ouais je sais
c'est au niveau des au niveau du
vocabulaire au niveau de des gestes au
niveau de quoi ouais beaucoup au niveau
du vocabulaire les gestes ça a pas été
jusqu'à une menace physique d'accord
mais c'est vrai que voil au niveau des
de la parole au niveau de de plein de
choses quel genre de choses au niveau du
vocabulaire quoi il parlait mal à à son
père quoi il s'agaçait s'agaçait il
répondait à son
papa il s'agaçait beaucoup il s'agaçait
beaucoup ça vous le notiez sur le carnet
de bord ça je le notais vous disez quoi
aujourd'hui Alain Fab bien à traité son
père de telle chose ou telle chose c'est
ça voilà il a répondu à son père son
père je pense que une grande partie des
Français connaissent bien l'on et son
caractère ouis donc il suffisait que
monsieur donlon lui dise une chose un
peu voilà qu'un papa serait susceptible
de dire à son fils à mécontentement tout
simplement et puis c'est vrai que Alan
Fabien aurait pu pouvait sortir de ses
gonds et lui répondre d'une façon je
dirais pas jusqu'à agressive mais un peu
vous avez passé 5 mois euh nonstop avec
eux quasiment donc là donc vous vous
êtes quand même un témoin clé de
l'affaire de ce qui se dit puisque
aujourd'hui on se dit voilà d'un côté
euh il y a une partie des enfants qui
disent que au contraire euh que euh euh
Anouchka profite de l'état de son père
pour abuser de lui et de l'autre on dit
que voilà que les les les les les fils
au contraire ont un comportement euh
limite avec leur père c'est ça Gil il
manque de respect c'est ça en fait ce
que vous avez noté c'est que le le plus
jeune des enfants manquaent de respect à
son père régulièrement vous avez assisté
à des échanges dans ce senslà j'ai
assisté à des échanges un peu muscl un
peu musclés si on veut musculature non
pas mais voilà c'estd en fait moi je
suis là pour ça justement je suis là
pour ça j'aurais pu être là parce que il
y a des choses qui ont été dites ces
derniers jours moi je alors c'est quoi
justement parce que ce qui ce qui dit
sur Anouka pour vous c'est c'est c'est
n'importe quoi mais complètement et puis
je trouve ça dommage parce que moi je
m'entendais avec les trois enfants je
vais pas dire je suis mieux avec anuska
ou avec alin Fabien Antony je
m'entendais avec les trois enfants et
peut-être encore aujourd'hui bon là je
pense que ils sont pas spécialement
courants donc peut-être en vouloir mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que j'aurais
pu être là pour défendre entre
guillemets les dire que un autre enfant
aurait pu dire sur Antony mais là vous
ce qui vous a gêné c'est ce qui a été
dit sur Anouka mais oui complètement
pourquoi parce que dites-nous qu est
Anouka c'est quoi c'est c'est celle qui
est c'est celle qui le plus proche de la
plus proche sonerre elle a déjà eu un
comportement
elle voilà qui peut être un mauvais
comportement avec son père ou pas du
tout Anka quand je vais voir quand je
vais voir là h et que je lui dis que sa
fille arrive
ouais il est comme un fou comme un fou
ouais c'est vraiment c'est ça ou il est
comme un fou il est là il demande à
l'infirmière de de de voilà de le
préparer et cetera limite de lui mettre
un petit coup de peigne voyez il est
comme un fou quand Anouchka arrive ça y
est il faut voyez il demande à
l'infirmière pareilfin il demandeà quand
vous entendez des c'est Anthony qui dit
qu'il va porter plainte qui a poré
plainte d'ailleurs contre Anouchka euh
est-ce que vous comprenez quand ils
disent que c'est quoi qu' qu'elle abuse
de son père de qu'elle met en danger
aussi leur pèrece que vous répondz à ça
parce qu'elle veut l'amener en suisseou
c'est tout le débat est là trait pour un
traitement tout le débat est là alors
justement ça c'est important parce que
là vous êtes vraiment un témoin quand
même cl ah moi je suis là que pour dire
la vérité je suis pas là pour enfer
certains et remonter les autres moi je
suis là pour dire la vérité parce que ça
fait quelques jours que je suis pas très
bien parce que je suis quand même donc
je me sentais un peu obligé de venir et
parler avait emmené son père en Suisse
pour une seule raison d'après ce que
j'ai vu et ce que j'ai entendu et je
pense que que c'est celle-là anuska
avait emmené son père parce que son père
il doit il doit faire des tests il doit
faire des examens tous les deux voire 3
mois en Suisse chez des grands
professeurs d'après C dire et d'après ce
que j'ai vu et entendu donc monsieur
Delon doit aller en Suisse pour
justement continuer son checkup et
cetera et cetera les garçons sont contre
mais non tu comprends ici on a ce qu'il
faut alors je vais me faire sûrement
lycher plus tard mais il y a pas de
souci j'assume mais c'était un médecin
de campagne qui soignait Alain Delon on
n pas en train de parler de quelqu'un
qui n'aurait peut-être pas les moyens de
d'avoir des professeurs d'être suivi
c'est un médecin de campagne elle est
très gentille cette dame il y a pas de
souci mais franchement aucun professeur
n'est venu voir Monsieur Delon depuis
que je suis là-bas aucun le seul médecin
qui est venu c'est une charmante dame
médecin de campagne donc encore une fois
c'est pour ça je me dis je j'ai rien
contre les mé campagne loin de là bien
au contraire mais moi je pense que les
les garçons là ils sont complètement
perdus sur cette histoire là Anouka veut
emmener son père pour une seule bonne
raison c'est ça c'est pour les checkup
et bien sûr parallèlement à ça ben elle
sera plus proche de son père parce que
tout le monde le sait habite Genève donc
elle aurait envie d'avoir son père à
côté d'elle et puis alin Delon il a
envie de la suivre en fait finalement
puce qu'il a il a tout son toute sa tête
et et s'il lui fait confiance pourquoi
je comprends pas même pas le le débat
alors justement a toute sa tête ou pas
ah c'est ça bonne question question ou
moi je je suis pas médecin pour vous
dire il a toute sa tête par contre il
vous parlait vous répondez exactement
c'est ce que j'allis en venir je suis
pas médecin pour vous dire il a toute sa
tête ou il l'a pas cependant ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que moi quasiment
toutes les après-midis et ben je buvais
le café avec Monsieur Delon j'ai
peut-être un privilège que j'ai pour
certains donc je vous le dis clairement
quasiment toutes les après-midis je
buvais un café avec Monsieur Deon je lui
donnaé des enfin on mangeit ensemble on
se faisait un petit un 4hur il adore ça
et et voilà je parlais avec lui il Me'
raconé des histoires que à la Brûlerie
m'a raconté d'histoire du château de La
Brûlerie donc c'est son domaine à dou
mais donc pour vous donc pour vous il
est il est pas dans un état enfin il
comprend il est conscient mais carrément
d'accord moi quand quand quand j'entends
il est fou il peut pas ceci il peut pas
cela mais franchement je suis je suis à
bassour parce que ce que j'entends et
c'est pour ça que suis là aujourd'hui
même pour Monsieur don peut-être qu'il
va me dire de quoi tu te mêles toi il va
sûrement me le dire peut-être si je le
rois mais la vérité c'est pour lui que
jeis je suis là alors il y a eu un
enregistrement d'Alain Fabien euh qui a
apparemment enregistré sa sœur aussi et
des discussions àez dépend exactement
alors moi l'enregistrement il dit pas
grandchose en fait hein c'est pas fou
fou désolé hein l'enregistrement je sais
pas si vous voulez on peut écouter une
partie de l'enregistrement mais vous
allez nous dire vous allez réagir Fabien
et Chami mais vous écoutter voilà il a
enregistré sa sœur à son Insul lors d'un
échange avec son père
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
je suis fatigué
papa ouais je suis fatigué je suis
énervé ce soir à cause de tout ce qui se
passe papa
oui moi on est en train de m'enterrer et
toi on est en train de te prendre pour
un
débile je sais
papa il faut que tu te méfies
surtout un débile
quoi une fille qui manipu qui manipule
son père bah ouais mais papa il va
peut-être falloir dire un
truc parce que là tu le piège il va se
refermer sur toi là le piège alors euh
voilà c'est après la suite c'est pas ouf
hein vraiment l'impression voilà c'est
pas des révélations incroyables euh
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ch
je pense que c'est c'est franchement
c'est complètement je sais pas pourquoi
il a fait ça là Fabien il a voulu
répondre à à l'avocat de de Anouchka qui
a qui a pris la parole sur BFM TV
dimanche à 18h45 bien et qui affirmait
qu'il était fatigué comme un homme de 88
89 ans mais que il était parfaitement
clair lucide enfin et cetera qu' avait
aucun problème c'est ça la question il
répondait pas aux questions vraiment en
même temps du journaliste mais donc il a
il a balancé ça à Alain Fabien pour
montrer un petit peu que quand elle lui
fait répéter tro quatre fois le mot BFM
pour qu'il entende bien puiss s news et
cetera d'accord c'est pour ça qu'il a
balancé ça il balancé parce que c'est
une réponse à l'avocat qui qui qui voilà
qui défendait juste parce que c'est vrai
que ce que vous nous avez dit à
inststant donc Alain Delong il comprend
tout à fait ce qu'on lui dit il comprend
la guerre entre ses enfants là il
compren il comprend tout de ce qu'on lu
d'accord là ce qui a été ça c'est
important SC le procureur
sinterroge pas la vie du procureur à la
rigueur ce qu'on pourrait qu'on pourit
reprocher et c'est même pas un reproche
quand je vais vous le dire même vous ça
va peut-être vous faire sourire c'est
qu'il entend mal à 88 ans ou c'est
possible monsieur Dolon alin il est vous
le connaissez encore une fois il a son
caractère il veut pas mettre ses
sonotones on se bat tous les jours quand
je dis on c'est l'infirmière et même moi
des foiselle m'appelle elle me dit
chamille s'il te plaît tu peux me donner
un coup de main et tout il veut pas il
veut pas mettre ses sonoton moi quand je
parle avec lui je me mets à côté de lui
je prends une chaise je m'installe à
côté de lui et on discute et je lui
parle dans l'oreille pour qu'il entende
voilà oui c'est vrai que et puis à cause
de d'une d'une de ses maladies il il a
un petit peu la gorge aussi moi moi au
début il parlait très bien il me criait
dessus ça c'était très bien aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'il a il la voix un peu on
dirait que comme si qu'il avait un rume
un peu en roué mais d'après la médecin
c'était à cause de cette maladie il
comprend l'Ance que vous disz c'est que
il comprend ce qu'on ce qu'on lui vous
avz une dernière question prchainement
mais est-ce que réellement il comprend
par exemple que ses deux fils sont en
train de vouloir là le spolier ou d'être
contre sa fille ça doit lui faire mal
que les deux filles soient contre
Anouchka mais complètement complètement
complètement encore une fois moi quand
je vous dis Anouka arrive quand je lu
dis que oui Anka arrive il est il est
heureux et quand je lu parle de certains
autres enfants qui arrivent ah ouais il
est malheureux lesquel lesquels après il
en a pas 5
an ouais c'est
vrai juste vous dire quelque chose que
vous avez dit quelque chose bah oui
après le le B le bisou fouux je vous
dire quelque chose ma belle-mère tin
turnner est en Suisse je vais vous dire
quelque chose vous avez vous avez dit
quelque chose qui est très juste que la
médecine en Suisse
est redoutable est incroyable temps plus
que parce que je vais vous dire quelque
chose ma ma belle-mère qui était qui
avait un peu perdu la tête qui a eu un
rein en moins a été transféré en Suisse
parce que les soins sont intensifs et
les Suisses azurique en Allemagne Suisse
allemande sont beaucoup plus forts que
les soins français effectivement pour
assister les gens qui sont pour non
écoutez magine de la santé j'ai pas
la Suisse est très très très très
très
mag der truc j'ai une dernière chose
dernière chose qui a son importance très
rapide c'est qu'en fait on reproche
aussi deux choses qu'on reprochait Anka
c'était
le le fait d'emmener son père en Suisse
et la deuxième d'être pas assez présente
moi je peux vous dire que tout le temps
que j'étais là Anouka au début elle
venait énormément de temps et là faut
pas oublier une choseka c'est une mère
de famille elle a un gose de 3 ans et
demi en Suisse qu'elle ne peut pas tout
le temps tout le temps être là mais elle
est là au maximum de du temps c'est vrai
que je l'ai vu très souvent
Douch oh ben c'est très simple euh au
mois de juin la la mairie de ville
neuvlerois a été incendier le CCAS
c'està-dire le le Centre Communal
d'Action Sociale est parti en fumée
comme vous le voyez et le lendemain il y
a eu une attaque du poste de police et
lors de cette attaque du du poste de
police une première porte a été fracturé
ils ont versé de
l'essence à l'intérieur du local et
c'est été un miracle que euh les les
agents de police ne brûlent puisque en
définitive la bas est arrivé une
extrémiste et ça permis de de
d'empêcher ce drame et donc logiquement
quand j'ai vu que cette
famille demander une aide une aide de
Noël qu'on fait une petite aide en
réalité 60 € 60 € pour TR personnes he
bon puisque la composition familiale
c'est TR personnes hein donc le père la
mère et le fils et donc dans ce dans ce
cadre là quand on a vu ça on s'est dit
c'est c'est pas possible vu la gravité
des des éléments et je tiens à préciser
que ce n'est pas une aide une aide
légale une aide prévu par l'État c'est
une c'est un petit signe qui est donné
par la munici
accpagner à l'AS de Noël il est majeur
le jeune pour vous ses parents
doivent-ils doivent payer encore les les
les conséquences de de ces acte mais
c'est toute la famille il se trouve dans
le cercle familial alors certes il est
tout jeune majeur mais il n'empêche que
il se trouve dans le cercle de
responsabilité de la famille parce que
c'est trop facile de venir postuler pour
les droit ou ouais c'est exactement ils
sont à TR alors c'est très facile de
postuler pour les droits hein et pour
les devoirs à ce moment il rrouv tout se
donc il y a il y a un petit un petit
souci de responsabilité dans tout ça
donc voilà euh on va voir qui est
d'accord avec Monsieur le Maire
Géraldine euh oui moi moi je pense que
effectivement à part les humanistes ici
qui ont un grand cœur moi je trouve que
ça ça ça mérite quand même d'être d'être
essayé je vois pas pourquoi et à quel
titre on vandalise les mairies on brûle
les drapeaux on vandalise les écoles les
commissariat et comme ça en toute
impunité et je trouve que c'est malgré
tout un bon signal puisqueà partir du
moment où il est il a dit 19 ans mais il
n'a rien eu au final il a eu du surcis
avec un ouais c'est ça du surcis un
stage qui fera ou qui fera pas et qui
servira de toute façon à rien donc de
toute façon voilà donc je trouve que
c'est quand même un bon signal de dire
en gros aux parents ben en fait vous
êtes responsable de vos enfants et aux
enfants et quand vous faites de la merde
en fait et ben vos parents payent le
truc et je trouve que c'est bien quand
ils sont mineurs ou c'est pour ça quand
vit sous le toit de sous le toit de ses
parents moi je trouve excusez-moi je
vois pas en quoi vandaliser des écoles
brûler des commissariats je vois pas
quel est le rapport avec la mort de Na
en fait donc c'est juste des ordes de
sauvag et donc on les punit et on leur
montre de quoi il sagit vous êtes
d'accord a ce que VI dire oui oui bien
sûr je suis d'accord et en plus c'est un
dispositif qui est complètement
différent quoi on est on est dans une
petite aide pour payer un un cadeau de
Noël un cadeau de Noël à la hauteur de
60 € très franchement c'est
pas sy symbole très
important non c'est pas un truc de fou
ce que je vais dire mais on pe prouver
il y a pas des truc de fou qui sont dit
dans cette émion mais pour moi il y a
encore une histoire de logique un petit
peu enfin la personne elle a 19 ans on
connait pas leur vie on sait même pas si
il est tout le temps chez ses parents
s'il y est pas com
personam par sa pas si découche s'il est
vraiment encadré si ses parents sont pas
au bout du rouleau justement de de vivre
ça et ils en peuvent plus le
ENF mais non mais il y a rien qui je
suis pas du tout en train de justifier
qu' qu'on brle école juste en train de
justifier les parents ils sont peut-être
le désar total et j'aurais préféré qu'on
envoie cette personne en prison s'il
faut voilà s'il mérite la prison il va
en prison mais qu'on pénalise pas les
parents qui sont sûrement au bout du
rouleau et on sait même pas si leur
fille leur fils il découche pas s'il vit
vraiment avec eux ce qui vous dérange
c'est qu'il soit majeur exactement il
est majeur et je pense que c'est
personne à lui non mais j'aimerais bien
avoir la réponse de Didier gonzalz mais
non mais justement
il bah lui
hein alors c'est pas lui c'est personne
donc c'est pas sa que c'est lui c'est
lui donc on sait que c'est lui puisqu'il
est il est majeur et condamné on sait
c'est lui a-t-il est-ce qu'il y a une
excuse de minorité non donc très bien il
est pleinement responsable est-ce que il
a une composition familiale difficile
mère isolé et cetera abandonné et tout
pas du tout parents normal enfin
situation familiale normale on a juste
eu des gens
à ce moment on
s'isole chez S
parents
imaginons par la
responsabation moment on est dans un
milieu
[Musique]
problc son pas d' dis le sondage
j'aimais bien qu'on voit déjà un petit
peu le sondage là s'il vous plaît pour
voir si j'ai raison voilà je comprends C
décision je suis à 94 % d'accord avec
vous voilà je suis d'accord avec le
public alors vas-y dis dis tes trucs et
puis tu vois bien que tu es un
loser merci c'est encourageant non mais
Monsieur le Maire ça n'a pas de sens il
a 19 ans il a été condamné il a un stage
de citoyenneté qu'il va payer et
lui-même dit je veux voir le maire je
veux payer moi je veux payer je veux
payer mais laissz laissz à ma mère ce
petit chèque pourquoi Vous sanctionnez
cette mère de famille exemplaire parce
que son fils a fauté vite oui ben
écoutez c'est pas compliqué je l'attends
toujours cette émetier voyez j'ai invité
seule la maman est venue on l'a toujours
pas et d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
dans un autre média il a dit que de
toute façon il ferait jamais le travail
d'intérêt général alors que justement
nous lui demandons de venir pour qu' il
démarre un commencement de réparation
alors que pensez-vous de
l'ensemble qui Coti qui paye qui eux se
lèvent le matin et ne casse pas ne brûl
pas ne ne commettent pas ces actes de
sauvagerie vous voulez payer qu'est-ce
que vous voulez lui offrir un cadeau de
Noël peut-être peut-être un mortier ou
une barre je sa pas non c'est pas bien
il a été condamné en jus' il pas été
condamnéam civil pas au
civil alors je tiens à préciser quelque
chose parce que c'est super important
parce qu'on peut le voir on voit que
c'est signé à la Alb et dans la les
dernières menaces qu'on a encore reçu
c'était c'était cré en arabe mais avec
une photocopie euh il y a des éléments
que je peux pas donner puisque la
gendarmerie m'a m'a demandé de pas les
donner il faut pas rentrer dans les
amalgames puisque aujourd'hui il y a
plusieurs indices en fait qui qui
pourrait laisser à croire que cette
personne voudrait faire passer tout
ça par une certaine communauté alors que
absolument pas donc moi je demande c'est
qu'on attende vraiment le résultat de
l'enquête et qu'on rentre pas dans les
AM g ou quoi que ce soit enfin il y a
plusieurs indications sur les courriers
qu'on a reçu qui laissent largement à
penser à croire que je pense qu'il ils
aimeraient trop aussi que je me mette
demain à à insulter cette communauté
alors que non j'essaierai de garder
cette droiture que j'essaie de faire
quand il y a un problème en Palestine je
le condamne mais quand il y a aussi des
attentats terroristes je les condamne
aussi et je continuerai de faire les
choses dans ce sens là Morgan
aujourd'hui olivoli m'a dit que vous
étiez vraiment très très très atteinte
que vous oui moi moi le deuxième
courrier c'est moi qui l'ai reçu pas le
premier c'est Olivier quielle à la boîte
aux lettres oui on va le mettre he pour
nos téléspectateurs voilà le deuxième
c'est moi qui l'ai reçu et je peux vous
dire euh que ma réaction a été bah la
réaction d'une personne humaine d'une
maman aussi avant tout et quand j'ai vu
cette photo euh de la fille d'Olivier
enfin oui je me suis mise à trembler
j'ai eu un étourdissement je me suis
effondré c'est mais ça m'a pris au corps
directement c'est c'est c'est pas
admissible c'est pas concevable c'est ça
ça tue moi j'ai peur la nuit quand le
quand quand le le la nuit tombe
je flippe quoi je regarde je je dors
plus je me réveille la nuit en sursaut
mais vous vous pouvez pas vous
imaginer ce que ce que ce que je
m'imagine vous dormez plus vous vivez
plus là mais je dors plus je vis plus je
non j'arrive plus j'ai peur voilà j'ai
peur et je veux que ça s'arrête et je
vous remercie de nous recevoir sur ce
plateau parce que j'espère et on essaie
tout et on fera tout ce qui tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour que ça bouge quoi
pour pour pour pas que cette plainte
soit classée sans suite et et qu'on
arrive à trouver l'ADN et et puis les
empreintes de ces gens-l qui vont qui
ont peut-être fauté à l'envoi de ce
courrier je ne sais pas et je vous
remercie de nous recevoir sur ce plateau
vraiment non mais c'est normal mais je
tiens à le signaler quand même Cyril
parce que tu on le sait maintenant j'ai
quand même pas mal de contact et j'ai
envoyé des messages à tout le monde et
le seul qui a répondu présent encore une
fois c'est toi et il faut savoir le dire
parce que c'est facile de cracher
toujours sur sur les mêmes par rapport à
des prises de position mais je pense que
quand on a animateur télé aujourd'hui
c'est pas toujours facile non plus et à
chaque fois tu es quand même le seul à
répondre présent et moi j'ai pas de
honte à le dire parce que aujourd'hui
cette parole médiatique moi j'en ai
besoin pour que ça soit entendu au plus
haut niveau qu'est-ce qu'il t'ont dit
d'ailleurs les policiers je crois qu'ils
t'ont dit quoi tu leur dit que tu allais
médiatiser la alors exactement j'en ai
parlé aux gendarmes et ils m'ont dit
écoute olive enfin on voit que il y a
ces dépôt de plainte on voit que ça
grandit petit à petit et même eux ils se
sentent impuissants parce que je le
répète ils font leur taf et ils m'ont
dit je pense que tu as raison
aujourd'hui de passer à une étape
supérieure pour que ça puisse se savoir
parce que c'est pareil on le sait tous
sur les réseaux sociaux il y a tout et
n'importe quoi qui sont racontés après
derrière chez toi directement c'est
exactement et aujourd'hui moi j'avais
besoin j'avais besoin que ça soit
entendu médiatiquement et et je le redis
moi je te remercie franchement je te
remercie es très ému olive Oliv et
Morgan aussi je sais que vous êtes maisi
je suis inquiet surtout je suis inquiet
parce que tu vois tu as posé cette
question qui est vachement pertinente
quand quand tu demandes à Morgan est-ce
que je devrais arrêter tout ça et je
suis obligé de me poser cette question
parce que j'ai l'impression que à
travers mes prises de position le le
combat que je suis en train de mener
j'ai pas envie de bousiller de la vie de
ma fille non plus et quand tu as ta
fille en pleure au téléphone et qui te
dit papa tu as vu les gens enfin comment
ils sont et et c'est pas les gens c'est
une certaine catégorie de personnes pour
pouvoir en arriver là et ouais je me
pose des questions aujourd'hui mais moi
le combat que je mène c'est le combat
d'une vie en fait je sais que ça peut
être compliqué à comprendre pour
certaines personnes il y a encore un an
et demi j'étais sur ce plateau et je
dénonçais l'inflation grandissante qu'on
allait prendre en pleine gueule et on
est en plein dents et je pense me pas
beaucoup me tromper sur certains sujets
que que que je peux exploiter peut-être
que des fois je me trompe sur d'autres
c'est à la rigueur mais est-ce qu' en
France on a encore le droit de
s'exprimer moi la vraie la vraie
question en fait elle est là est-ce
qu'on a encore le droit de parler en
France pense que c'est qui qu est-ce qui
t'en veut tu penses je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de jalousie derrière tout ça on
va pas se mentir aujourd'hui on vit dans
une société qui est très très jalouse et
si tu fais un peu trop de vu si on voit
un peu trop ta gueule sur les réseaux si
tu fais un peu de télé et un petit peu
de radio derrière c'est encore pire et
ouais je crois que malheureusement plus
les gens sont en souffrance plus ils
deviennent méchants plus les gens
souffrent de leur quotidien et plus ils
deviennent méchants sincèrement moi
c'est ce que je ressens et moi
j'aimerais quand même que tu que tu
parles de ce jeune homme qui t'a appelé
ce ce jeune avec ce père obsédé qui a
des photos de partout chez lui de nous
truc de fou un truc de fou j'ai un gamin
qui m'appelle et qui me dit écoute olive
je suis obligé de venir vers toi je vais
te donner le numéro et l'adresse de mon
père puisque il nous oblige à regarder
tes lives dans le salon il met le home
cinéma à bloc il y a des alarmes et il
nous oblige à regarder en fait ce que tu
fais au quotidien il a des alarmes sur
son téléphone dit que tu te déclenches
en live et il nous oublig à regarder ce
que tu fais enfin j'ai l'impression que
j'ai j'ai récupéré tous les taréss de la
terre non mais sincèrement ça ça me fait
peur non non ils sont chez moi
merci il y a Christine qui est avec nous
également Christine qui a reçu
énormément de menaces tu as été mis sous
protection policière
euh moment oui oui j'ai attend tu
toujours sur protection policier euh
même si je le suis plus je le dirais pas
mais la protection c'est un peu on a
changé un petit peu de style de
protection mais pendant plus de 2 ans
c'était une protection rapprochée
permanente et reç des vraies menaces que
tu peux nous raconter no téléspectateurs
et ben en fait dès que j'ai commencé
l'émission Face à l'info ne serait-ce
que parce que j'ai fait cette émission
parce que certaines personnes pour ne
pas citer HX Zéon sur le plateau ne
plaisait pas un certain public sans même
connaître mes positions parce que je
rejoins ce que vous disiez vous disiez
on on veut vous faire taire mais parce
que vous dites vous avez des opinions
mais même sans dire des opinions sans
donner son opinion aujourd'hui on est
menacé de mort donc et et mais les
menaces étaient très sérieus que vous
avez été mis protection policière
qu'est-ce que vous avez reçu comme
menace les plus la plus sérieuse qu'on
va me décapiter ça revenait
systématiquement que si j'allais tel ou
tel endroit on allait me décapiter qu'on
voulait voir ma tête tomber sur rau vous
avzçu des menaces lettre personnel
lettre au travail lettre à la maison
lettre par par sur le sur les réseaux
sociaux celui qui a été
condamné
récemment finalement avec la l'enquête
de la police on s'est rendu compte que
c'était je pensais que c'était 6 mois de
harcèlement sur les réseau sociaux
c'était 2 ans et demi hartiellement sur
les réseaux sociaux il avait mon
portable il m'appelait bon je lu réponds
jamais au numéro masqué mais il appelait
un peu voilà il a cherché à avoir mon
portable euh il a payé pour avoir mon
numéro de portable et cetera et et
jusqu'à maintenant c'est heureusement
sur les réseaux sociaux il y a un
certain rituel qui s'est mis en place où
les gens dénoncent et très vite les les
posts sont supprimés mais je comprends
la terreur que que vous pouvez vivre
parce que vivre en permanence en se
demandant euh qu'est-ce qui va se passer
qu'est-ce qui va se passer demain on est
ah j'avais peur je pense comme beaucoup
de chroniqueurs aussi ici où on se
regarde devant on regarde derrière on
sait pas ce qui va se passer on regarde
dans le parking et cetera et lorsque
j'ai eu la protection ça a été un ouf de
soulagement ça a été vraiment un ouf de
soulagement j'avais peur de l' prendre
j'avais refusé à plusieurs reprises au
tout début des menaces de mort vous
m'aviez appelé j'ai pas oublié ça m'a
beaucoup réconforté je m'appelle Marline
Chapa qui était au gouvernement m'avait
appelé et Emmanuel Macron m'avait appelé
aussi j'avais refusé à ce momentl plus
importante du pays
hein et j'avais j'avais refusé au tout
début la protection policière et puis
après lorsque je me suis fait aussi à
palier sur une terrasse de café en plein
16e arrondissement là on est on est
passé quoi c'était une femme qui était
un peu dingue qui qui voulait vraiment
elle s'énervait sur
elle c'était dingue je suis restée sur
place un peu calmement mais euh vous m'
insulté elle m'a fait beaucoup de de
doigts d'honneur elle est venue
m'insulter euh euh elle a fait le tour
de mon déjeuner la personne avec qui
j'étais plusieurs fois je pense que
j'aurais été avec une femme ou bien avec
un enfant çaaurait été pire j'étais avec
un homme heureusement c'était un ancien
militaire j'étais un peu tranquille mais
je veux dire c'està dire qu'on se dit on
sait pas à quel moment ça va vous tomber
dessus et après tu sors plus tu mets
plus le nez dehors tu vas juste à ton
boulot et cetera donc avec la protection
policière ça m'a permis de sortir ça m'a
permis d'être un peu plus tranquille
mais euh c'est vrai en lorsque j'entends
leur témoignages j'ai beaucoup hésité à
porter plainte parce qu'on se dit qu'il
y a une efficacité peut-être au niveau
de la police et après une certaine
indifférence au niveau de la justice
heureusement dans ce cas-là la justice a
été jusqu'au bout mais c'est vrai que ce
n'est pas toujours le cas et c'est vrai
que ce que je don souvent dans ma
position c'est le fait qu'on veuille
vous faire taire il y a plus de liberté
d'expression il y a plus de liberté
d'expression en France comme vous dites
on peut regarder autre chose comme vous
dites on peut il y a 200 chaînes télé en
France 900 radio on peut regarder autre
chose on peut zapper on peut éteindre sa
télé mais non les gens veulent vous
faire
[Musique]
taire ce qui s'est passé dans les je
pense que vous allez pouvoir comprendre
ce que je vous dis j'ai essayé j'ai je
je vais enyer je vous Prom c'est pas
parce que je suis pas vraiment au niveau
contrairement à Myriam qui comprend tout
bien sûr non mais vous vous dispuz après
c'est votre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
problème je vais vous expliquer quelque
chose de simple dans les maladies
infectieuses ça fait longtemps que je
les maladies infectieuses dans les
maladies infectieuses les choses
commencent par un diagnostic c'est il
faut savoir si le malade a la maladie ou
non l'étude de base qui a été utilisée
partout y compris par l'OMS c'est une
étude anglaise qui s'appelle
recoverie et et qui a été l'étude qui
qui a fait la loi surtout dans l'étude
recovery pour inclure les malades
c'estàdire pour rentrer les malades dans
le protocole il n'était pas nécessaire
de faire un diagnostic de covid le
médecin décidé je crois que c'est un
covid je n'ai jamais vu de ma vie une
étude scientifique faite comme ça et
d'ailleurs il l'annon c'est écrit si
vous savez lire l'anglais vous le lirez
15 % des gens qui ont été inclus n'ont
pas eu de test PCR voilà on sait pas ce
qu'il deuxièmement quel est le
traitement qu' leur ont donné le
traitement qu'il leur ont donné c'est
écrit aussi suffit de le lire le
traitement qu' leur on donné le premier
jour c'est 2,4 g
d'hydroxychlorquine et ensuite si vous
c'est plus facile parce que c'est du
français si vous avez toujours le
tempsgul de lire vous vous lirez la
thèse de notre ancien ministre qui
s'appelle Brown qui a fait sa thèse sur
la toxicité de
l'hydroxychloroquine et il marque à
partir de 2,5 g par jour
d'hydroxychloroine l'hydroxychloroine
peut devenir toxique elle est très
toxique quand on en donne 10 g mais à
partir de 2,5 g par jour elle devient
toxique tout ça c'est des données de
base c'est-à-dire que des choses comme
ça aent pu être publiées et pu devenir
des articles de référence c'est un truc
qui est stupéfiant quant à ce qui s'est
passé sur l'étude de l'OMS je vais vous
le dire ouais donc encore une fois moi
j'ai fait à peu près 10000 dosages
hydroxychlorquine dans ma vie dans mon
laboratoire parce que les gens ne
savaient pas le faire on m'envoyait les
deux es hydroxyclorquin de toute la
France et du monde entier parce que les
gens ne savaient pas doser
hydroxychlorquine on a même publié une
méthode de de de simplifié de de dosage
hydroxychloroine qu'est-ce qui a été
fait en en en France dans le cadre de ce
qu'ils ont
appelé Discovery c'est parce qu'ils ont
découvert au lieu de faire comme les
Anglais qui avaient donné 4atre fois la
dose ils ont donné les 2/ de la dose
c'estàd ils ont donné 400 mg au lieu de
donné 600 mg moi ça fait 30 ans que que
j'écris que je donne 600 mg par jour
pendant plus d'un an aux gens et je vais
vous dire une deuxième chose mais je je
je l'ai déjà dit et puis que vous me
croyez que vous me croyez pas comme
comme vous le savez je je m'en fiche
comme de l'an 40 ça j'imagine donc vous
avez bien raison d'ailleurs s'en bat les
couilles je vois pas pourquoi votre
opinion serait plus importante que la
mienne alors que vous savez pas de quoi
vous parle moi je sais de quoi je parle
absolument vous avez tout à fait raison
comme nous tous autour de cette table
d'ailleurs le le le
le le même jour je je je suis je suis
toujours pour des raisons qui m'étonnent
le seul consultant éditorial du Land 7
français il a pas d'autrre vous qu'
regarder la page du L éditorial
consultante toujours mon
problème tout ce que je vous dis vous
pouvez toujours le regarder enregistreer
vous allez voir si vous lisez pas tout
en anglais vous le faites traduire sur
Google c'est instantané
euh vous la prenez vraiment le même le
le même non je sais pas vous lui il m'a
dit ça lui m'a dit ça moi je m'en fous
je vous dis tout ce que je dis des
grands médecins professeur ce que vous
connaissez
je ce que vous connaissez je m'en fous
grand médecin ça ve rien dire moi je
fais 1,85 grand
médecin mais sauf que vous avez échoué
sur le covid et je comprends que ce soit
très très dur pour vous d'avaler ça
alors que vous êtes un professeur
brillantissime connu dans le monde éche
sur le covid en fait c'est un B inter
sidéral sur le covid et c'est impossible
pour vous de l'accepter vous avez réussi
tout mais non mais je suis pas je suis
pas CR je suisuseit mais c'est du théâre
moi je fais pas de théâtre j'essaie de
vousors pourquoi vous acceptez pas de
répondre avec vos à des confrères
médecins parce que c'est facile moi de
me démonter je suis une chroniqueuse je
suis pas médecin pourquoi vous acceptez
pas de parler à à des médecins qui sont
pas d'accord avec vous à vos détracteurs
sur des plateau télé AC tout ce que je
fais pouro vous acceptez
pas laiss parler prof parce que parce
que vous vous vous faites dans les gens
qui sont chez vous ils ont peut-être
tous le même niveau que vous
moi je je je je c'est bien possible donc
vous
pouvez j'en sais rien mais vous pouvez
parler vous dit avec un peu de mépris
comme si j'is une débile mais moi moi
vous savez je fait 20 ça fait 20 ans que
je suis le microbiologiste le plus dans
les débiles comme moi il y en a qui
achètent votre livre donc vous devriez
pas les mépriser hein vous méprise pas
je vous dis simplement que vous vous
comparez des gens qui ne sont pas
comparables j'ai ça fait depuis 20 j'ai
été dans le l'éditorial de tous les
journaux de maladies infectieuses du
monde sair je suis le plus cité depuis
20 ans de tous les microbiologistes du
monde et que donc quand vous avez un
pharmacocinéticien qui découvre la
maladie infectieuse et qui n'a jamais
soigné un malade et qui veut me donner
une leçon je lui parle pas voilà
exactement c'est pas compliqué parle pas
aux gens qui qui mais mais qui je vais
parler à un néphrologue raté je vais
parler à quoi à qui je vais parler vous
avez non mais enfin vous avez vu qui
vous entendez mais qui vous invitz mais
vous avez pas honte enfin vous invitez
des gens mais il faut inviter qui pour
être digne du professeur raou alors
profur RA ah votre reflet en fait dans
un miroir il faut inviter qui en fait
non non mais moi ce que je je je vos
types de débat d'ailleurs je je je je je
regrette de me retrouver dans ce type de
débat parce que je je parle pas avec les
gens comme vous d'habitude je le fais
pas j' bien compris je je je parle pas
dans les bistros non plus voyez donc je
je vous alors parce que lui il est digne
de vous alors mais c'est vous qui me
parlez moi je vous ai rien
demandé garder votre opinion pour vous
moi je m'en fous parler avec votre maman
votre cousine votre concierge je m'en
fous ça m'intéresse soyz pas méprisent
ma concierge elle vous adore par exemple
ah voilà très bien
je inellig il y en a beaucoup qui ador
le professeur en tout cas et en pratique
en tout cas et en
pratique le même pour que je puisse F de
parler si vous acceptez de pas
m'interrompre pour me raconter les
choses qui ne m'intéressent
guerre la même semaine pour le l CZ pas
impressionné quand même de la même
semaine pour le l j'envoie moi un
article qui était les 3700 premières
personnes que nous avions
testé cet article le l ne le lit pas
alors qu'encore une fois je je je
connais très bien l en même temps le l
m'envoie un article à reviewer dans cet
article REVV dont vous n'avez jamais
entendu parler mais que vous pouvez
retrouver puisque maintenant il est
publié dans un journal qui s'appelle
l'an rhumatologie les rhumatologues du
monde entier l'hydroxychloroquine vous
savez ça a été utilisé par des milliards
de personnes pour traiter le paltisme et
par des centaines de millions de
personnes pour traiter le lupus et
laéomatoïus à ces paologies là très bien
ils envoient un article en dis disant
nous allons voir si l'hydroxychloroquine
est associé là c'est pas trois osos qui
ont jamais vu de malade c'est on va voir
si l'hydroxychloroine donne plus de mort
que le traitement alternatif de la
polyartrite rhumatoïde vous demanderez à
vos grand médecins SS ont entendu parler
de ces médicaments qui est la
sulfadiazine d'accord 1 million dans
chaque bras
ouais il n'y a pas de surmortalité avec
l'hydroxychloroine comparé à la
sulfadizine dont jamais personne
1 million dans chaque bras voà je donne
un avis très favorable écoutez c'est
c'est vraiment c'est très intéressant
parce que quand vous avez traité 1
million de personnes les rhumatologues
il traitent pas pendant 10 jours comme
nous traité il d pendant 1 an 2 ans 3
ans 4 ans quand vous avez 1 million de
gens trés qui n'ont aucun accident
cardio-vasculaire ça a un sens ce qui se
passe c'est que le l dans un premier
temps ne le prend pas il prendra dans un
des bébés du qui s'appelle l rumatologie
où il est publié vous avez qu' regarder
tout ça c'est de la littérature et enfin
en même temps le Land qui n'a pas envoyé
à REVV publie un papier qui est l Gat
dans lequel ils annoncent qu'ils ont
traité 80000 personn dont la promotrice
est une ancienne p star
qui c'est beau elle est magnifique belle
fille lesordonn
pour annonce 10 % de mort et avec un
truc extraordinaire c'est là-dessus ça
c'est publié le vendredi je vous raconte
des choses vous avez qu'à les lire c'est
tout écrit ça c'est ch ça il a raison l
la le c'est écrit le vendredi moi j'ai
un ami à l'Élysée qui me dit Didier tu
peux me donner ton avis sur ce papier
ouais Thierry couon c'est pas un mystère
je dis écoute c'est gentil je passe le
weekend parce que je passe pas SEM à
travailler je te réponds lundi ouais le
lundi je regarde l'article
et entre-temps Verant avait dit la
chloroine tu on arrête tout le directeur
de l'OMS avait dit la chloroine tue on
arrête tout je lis ce papier qui est un
tissu d'annerie inouï dans lequel on
avait fait je pense que vous devez si
vous savez pas vous demanderez au grand
médecin que vous connaissez mais les
dans lequel on dit voilà on a des
données partout dont la France
d'ailleurs et on a étudié comme on le
fait aux États-Unis parce qu'on a le
droit de le faire aux États-Unis mais en
France on n' pas le droit de le faire on
dit alors quelle est l'ethnie des
patients en France qui ont eu cette
maladie et qui en sont morts c'est
illégal on n pas le droit de mettre sur
un papier lui il est maghrébain lui il
est juif lui il est on n pas le droit
c'est interdit en France d'accord donc
c'est un c'est une fausse information
les Australiens en même temps gueulent
en disant mais ils disent qu'ils ont
plus de covid dans leur série qu'il n'y
a eu de covid dans toute l'australieorte
quoi
d'accord moi je j'aiécrit une lettre qui
est accepté après elle s pas publié
parce que l'article sera rétracté donc
on va pas publier les lettres sur les
articles qui existent plusou il y a une
une série T des infectiologues anglais
écrivent en demandant est-ce que vous
êtes devenu complètement fou qui a
review ça et l'article est retiré et
là-dessus la décision qui avait été
prise et qui est toujours parce que le
Land l' rétracté mais l'article est
toujours disponible il est toujours cité
des centaines de fois d'accord et si
vous faites euh euh la bêtise
artificielle vous allez trouver la
bêtise artificielle bien sûr cet article
a été rétracté mais il mentionne qu'il y
a eu beaucoup de morts là voilà et donc
moi ma seule réponse à moi elle est pas
compliquée je je je vais pas euh aller
jouer avec des gens qui n'ont vu aucun
malade qui qui sont allés pêcher dans
les 1000 ou il y a eu 3000 à peu près
2500 études qui ont été faites sur le
traitement du covid si vous voulez
vraiment au lieu de demander au grand
médecin que vous connaissez vous
regardez un site qui s'appelle early C19
marquez-le marquez-le early c19.com vous
regardez ce soir voilà 2300 il regardent
tous les médicaments qui ont été
utilisés et contre quoi ils ont été
utilisés vous avez des données qui
tombent d'une manière absolument
étonnante exactement sur les même
données que nous donné précocément 70 %
de protection de la mortalité donné
tardivement il y a 40 % de protection de
la mortalité merci did je voulais vous
dire merci vous savez que êtes toujours
le bienvenu ici vous savez que je suis
fan de vous et que vraiment vous êtes
mon invité préféré sachez-le et voilà
Géraldine tu es contente des répondes de
professeur pe importe je pense que ça
lui est égal en tout je me suis régalé
voilà je dis encore ce soir ça ce livre
incroyable ni angélique ni diabolique
les antibiotiques ira où ça je lis tous
les Liv gens qui viennent ici celui-là
ti je te l'ofre celui-là tu vois au lie
de peut-être sur la médecine tu ferais
mieux d'être sur les meurtres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci